welcome to this video playing easygoing
from the Ukraine and its servants Aegean
let's check the yaroslav's era book very
promising young player from 1990 20
years old and his about to 6:30 rated in
freedom
okay let's try an aggressive opening
before the blue moon felt not really an
expert but let's hope he's not an expert
as well
okay what black gets in the blue multi
is a good development and good pieces I
thought this I thought he is an e4
player but a bit surprised that he
played default but okay very weak
recollection of of his play when I
played the European club cap in Slovenia
2011 in the first round we played the
Ukrainian team and he was in the lineup
playing on one of the lower BOTS which
tells you that the Ukrainian team was
very strong it they played with a couple
of nearly 2700 players ok so let's see
should I push yeah I guess I should push
d4 d5
going for a four possible I can play you
for himself
maybe if he should do that but I can
even yeah well ok but this is of course
a weakness 5 square but if I go Knight
g4 what is he playing and
okay wait wait the night of singing that
knight on c6 is a not so fast okay of
course I can play you for just give away
this yeah that's not necessarily bad I
mean but I don't want to do that Queen
this heaviness also battens yeah okay I
need you I need to play I need to play
yeah this looks very active but I'm the
position is full of weaknesses c5 is one
of them I think I should jettison the
spawn what I need to do is I need to
place my hope on on a very swift King
side attack with III Knight g4 this kind
of stuff yeah yeah this is clear I saw
that it's not I didn't blunder that but
it's it's too late to took care about
those kind of things and I can exchange
okay so Knight g4 Nigel for prom
yeah this is really a do or die opening
I mean no there is no kind of draw
whatever you just need to need to attack
us as quickly and fiercely as possible
but it's very interesting to play yeah
okay Queen age five is probably too
strong a medicine even for this game and
and now after was saying so let's see
what he's doing okay one possibility is
Queen age six age four moves and then
taking him or you three okay
yeah the bad thing is I'm running out of
pieces to sacrifice h3 let's see maybe I
can take F to rook F - hmm yeah this is
the other possibility I thought you look
at to look after Queen III Queen III how
does he protect Queen takes okay okay
come on let's do that it's funny it's
really like like caveman chess just the
tech with everything you got Queen if I
know I know I take here Queen takes
Queen see what you get get the book back
and what is this position now it's got
Queen f5 coming with the counter-attack
and this is even though this is a
problem it can take here I'd like to
push c3 but the Queen at high if it
looks really dangerous and if always
hanging so this is an additional problem
how do I play that maybe early take here
this threatens to take on a - Bishop
takes
he's got Bishop d5 Bishop d5 check ah
that's a shame
I completely overlooked that with the
mate to come
hmm that's terrible
I really overlooked that mm-hmm fun okay
it's not it's not over I hope it takes
b3 I play Queen d2 still attacking e2
I'm just a pawn down after all I am
sacrificed earlier and Bishop here for
instance I play d3 curious I wouldn't
have allowed that I think maybe it's not
not the problem but I don't see a move
now him
and don't does he threaten something
this check I have I have king of seven
that's not a problem
maybe Bishop here takes Queen takes tea
- it's not working with him to spend too
much time
idiotic such an exciting position and I
spoiled it yeah
two points at the time I'm warning ya
that's useless camelids resigned that
black resigns no let's check let's check
some of this some of this craziness
computer says this position is equal as
usual okay check you know man here
widest better check what the game okay
it took him you know what white is
better it looks very shaky but I don't
have a way to exploit it associated now
gifts and this means that was in much
better shape I need to direct tactical
idea and this is not not working
very interesting I mean this this
opening is really a guaranteeing an
exciting game I mean it's not not
correct correct sacrifice yeah probably
but it's it's very fun what should i do
I mean now the computer gives white
baguette whatever cannot really tell
what's going on it's it's really crazy
stuff Knight takes it wants to play
Knight takes let's have a brief look no
yes yeah this pretend I can play that
this is the computers point intending
attending Nagi form this is the computer
line check and now the amazing oh my oh
that's funny I mean the idea is he
doesn't need to take but the idea is of
course that this is very unhealthy for
the Queen
I'm going to go into win now check and
black promotes its pawns that's nice
yeah I completely create the game I hope
you enjoyed it